when do you give up I got a really great
question from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys Jeng who wrote in to say
'even when do you decide to give up when
things seem they get so hopeless and
there's no future market when we just
have to believe ourselves and keep going
no matter what happens but there's a lie
in believe if you notice so should we
keep lying to ourselves so this is a
great question and every entrepreneur
thinks about giving up at some point
multiple times it's something that
nobody talks about when we're out
talking about our businesses is always
the good stuff right you're meeting
other entrepreneurs they're always
telling you the good things that are
happening I just landed this new client
things are going really well but then
everybody struggles at some point in
their life and thinks about giving up
and doing something else everybody so
when do you actually decide to give up
and for me the answer is when you don't
have the passion for if you are still
passionate about what you're doing then
you have to keep going even if it's
hopeless even if you don't see a market
you'll figure it out if you are
passionate about it you're helping
people you have to keep going this is
your life's passion you got to keep
doing it if you're not passionate about
it that's when you give up then it's a
then it's a struggle right writing the
business is hard it's hard you have to
be a little crazy because you're doing
things that the don'tlet servicing
rationale that if you think logically
about it that doesn't make sense and
it's hard because if you look at if it
was as easy as find your passion and go
do that everybody would do it everybody
would be millionaires every word would
be entrepreneurs and yet we're not there
why because it's hard because following
your passion is an easy strategy but
it's hard to keep going it's easy for
one week to do but it's hard to do it
for years when you don't see the
momentum and it's only the successful
brave entrepreneurs that get through all
that crap all the doubt all the
insecurities all the lack of momentum
and they keep driving through and they
come out on the other side and they're
successful a lot of entrepreneurs they
start a business that they're not even
passionate about
at the beginning they think they can
make a lot of money if that's you you're
dead in the water like quit nap when you
give up and give up right now because
you're never gonna make it you start a
business just trying to make money stop
there are other businesses though that
you'll you'll lose interest in you might
be passionate about at the start and
you'll lose you'll lose that passion
over time and when that passion starts
to fade that's when the business is
going to just going to flounder it won't
do well so that's when you quit or you
sell but if you found the business you
love you still love doing it even though
you're not making money yet you don't
see momentum then you have to keep going
that's when you keep going let me give
you an example there are three
activities that I've tried as an example
so one was rock climbing one of
snowboarding when it salsa dancing rock
climb when I tried I tried it once day
one I hated it okay the the thing the
harness was in my crotch
I was uncomfortable you know I'm afraid
of heights it was not a great experience
for me and I never went back
snowboarding I picked up a couple years
ago and I was obsessed when I first
learned it was obsessed that got my own
board I went every day that the hills
was learning picking up new moves
getting better super quick and now I
still like it but I don't have I'm not
obsessed with it as much I don't have to
go every day to go snowboarding so I've
lost a little bit of the passion for it
and then there's salsa which I've been
doing for eight plus years and I still
love it and I love the music and I love
the community and I'm still out you know
20 hours a week doing salsa or dancing
or deejaying or whatever and so this is
the difference right there's some things
that you do there's some business ideas
you have that like rock climbing for me
you have no interest in or like
snowboarding you have a lot of interest
in at the start and then it fades or
like salsa where you have interest in
and it just keeps staying high right
those are the business ideally you want
to stick with the problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs is they look at the rock
climbing type of businesses and they'll
say I can make a lot of money here I
don't like that business I don't know
anything about that business I don't
want to be an expert in that business I
don't really want to work but I want to
make a lot of money so I'm going to jump
in
here that's a recipe for failure that's
why all these companies are shutting
down you're in the wrong business you're
not passionate about that don't go into
rock climbing
unless you're passionate rock climbing
then the entrepreneurs who focus on the
snowboarding business write the things
that you are really passionate I'm it
fades maybe it's over a year two years
five years ten years whatever over some
period of time a lot of businesses the
entrepreneurs their passion just fades
you change you become a different person
you're not interested in it anymore
and when that happens that's when you
quit you should be living your life
doing things that invigorate you and
bring you happiness right if your
business is not bringing you happiness
if you're not doing things you're
passionate about then you have to change
and maybe your company has grown to the
point where you can sell it to somebody
or the someone who can take over or
maybe you didn't get it off fast enough
and you're not making enough money and
the best thing to do is just to shut it
down but if you're in the business of
the salsa business where you love what
you're doing you still are obsessed with
it you're still in it you see how you're
helping people even if you haven't had
any momentum yet you're not seeing the
progress people tell you you're crazy
you're stupid if you love it you got to
keep going
you got to keep going you have to do
things in your life that you're
passionate about period so that's how
you make the decision that's when the
stop believe those are watching I'd love
to hear your thoughts leave a comment
below let me know what you think let me
know how you decided to stop your
business or if your passion or what
you're doing leaving the comments below
because I hope it will help inspire
other entrepreneurs who are facing the
same problems just like this video
thumbs up below click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon